oh hi guys I'm back in Los Angeles said
I'm gross and scummy and sweaty so let's
review some Billboard Music Award
fashion head judge not lest ye be judged
I make Internet videos so I'm always
[ __ ] judged
so let's judge Jennifer Lopez one do you
ever age - why didn't someone help you
out of that curtain that you walk
through before you got onto the red
carpet 3 what cute Jordin Sparks kinda
looks like JLo circa 1999 your dress
looks like fresh hot tar cute Kesha
looks really good with it cash are you
look beautiful what happened your skin
doesn't look real how did this happen
where's your signature gross what
happened how did it happen
Kesha you look so good what happened
Kesha
what happened Danica McKellar those ABS
are winning hooking up Carrie Underwood
we get it you are pretty and there this
dress looks like you're in the middle of
a Transformers transformation they
showed up to the event wearing a very
sophisticated lime green dress and then
all sudden you're like transform but
then you're like I had you these photos
real quick so only the top half started
transforming cute nicki minaj why so sad
you shown the top and boobs and the
bottom of your boobs were you sad
because you only wanted to show one and
what the other is that why were you sad
because you couldn't also show side boob
so sad
kill the Tasha Bedingfield I don't like
this girl I think she'd be fun to hang
out with unless she's a [ __ ] but she
seems fun unless she's a [ __ ] no she
seems fun but with a chance she could
pittle [ __ ] Shakira was your stylist
New Jersey cute whoa God the Jenners why
are they so robots what why does this
make me so uncomfortable what is
happening but they both understand
shoulders back tits up as a way to post
what I feel
somebody will recharge their batteries
ah cute Iggy Azalea what nationality's
hideous alien that's not phrases is it
also also it looks like Iggy Azalea was
like I see what you're doing JLo and I
can do one better look I put this weird
lace bodysuit underneath of it what now
lazy sterling oh my god Lindsey is
looking whimsical and adorable and a
little sexy girl there's like a pixie
decided to be inspired by the Pixies
huge Wiz Khalifa and Amber Rose
okay that's it for reviewing these Oh
Billboard Music Awards I hope you
enjoyed this time overall I'd say that
the fashions were fashion clothes they
were clothes first and foremost and
second of all they were on people's
bodies good job everyone
I don't know Grace's guide book com
pre-order now